all right there's a new partnership in
town ensuring our local seniors get what
they need
when it comes to health plans and also
health care take a look
matt you're with alignment health plan
and milo you're with p3 this is a
partnership right
it is a lineman health plan is a
medicare advantage plan in
nevada uh it's our first year in clark
county and we're really excited to be
here
and we have a huge partner p3 in the uh
in the county and they've got a very
broad network of providers and hospitals
and
we're super excited about the
partnership you know we do have about
30 primary care providers within our
medical group
and we have a very extensive network of
specialties and hospitals that
are ready to take care of patients milo
do you have any tips to help our viewers
you know compact this season yes
absolutely the first most important step
is to establish here with a primary care
provider
and then you know these are things i
usually tell my patients every year
get your flu vaccine every year make
sure that all your other vaccines are up
to date with
um you know uh be recommended from the
cbc guideline as well
and you know just to continue to
practice um health uh behaviors just you
know
staying social distance wash your hands
often
put on a mask if you're gonna be out in
public because our seniors are very very
vulnerable
healthcare plans can get really
expensive so how can our viewers
actually use their health benefits
and stick to a healthy budget that's a
great question
health care expenses are an extremely
important topic these days
and an alignment health plan we actually
keep
three things in mind as members choose
the right plan
that adds the most value to them we have
special benefits that go beyond
traditional health care
we have use it or lose it allowances
like over-the-counter drug
benefits and other benefits as
as an example 50 to 100 in over the
counter
benefits that you can literally just
swipe a card
at your local pharmacy which is a huge
value to a lot of our members
and then we have rewards for covered uh
covered preventive
services like the flu shot so you're
actually rewarded
for completing your preventative
services with your provider so my
biggest recommendation
is making sure that you establish q with
the primary
provider and build that relationship
with your primary care providers
by um you know attending annual wellness
visit even when you're feeling well
because during these appointments here
at p3 we encourage all of our patients
to
um participate in an annual wellness
visit where this is a time when you get
extended period of time with your
primary care providers to
go over your entire health history
making sure all of your vaccines are up
to date making sure that all of your
skin
preventive measures are also up to date
these type of appointments really does
help improve good habits
which will lead to the overall unhealthy
outcomes for everyone
certain supplements you know decrease
the effectiveness of your medications
um other medication will kind of uh you
know heighten some of those side effects
you know so you want to really check
to make sure that there's no
interactions with your prescription
medications
for more information on these
organizations the numbers are right
there on your screen las vegas now we'll
be right back